the Prime Minister now coming into
negotiation between the UK and the EU
there were those who said that reaching
a brexit agreement that worked for both
sides was an impossible task from the
start I rejected that council of despair
and set about negotiating a deal that
worked for the UK and the EU one that
delivered on the result of the
referendum and set us on course for a
prosperous future while maintaining a
close relationship with our friends and
neighbors thanks to the hard work of
both sets of negotiators that is what we
have today agreed I want to take a few
moments to speak directly to the British
people and explain what this deal means
first control of our borders not an
emergency break on free movement or a
promise of greater transition controls
in the future but an end to the free
movement of people in full once and for
all that is what this deal delivers it
will allow us to put in place an
immigration system based not on where
people come from but on the skills and
talents they have to offer that is in
our national interest second control of
our money not a reduction in our
membership fee not a bigger budget
rebate but an end to vast annual
payments being sent to the EU that is
what this deal delivers instead we will
be able to spend taxpayers money on our
priorities like the 394 million pounds
per week of extra investment we are
putting into our NHS that is in our
national interest third control over our
laws not just the return of some areas
of control from Brussels but an end to
the jurisdiction of the European Court
of Justice in the UK with our laws being
made in our country by democratically
elected politicians interpreted and
enforced by British courts that is what
this deal delivers and that is in our
national interest in agriculture it does
not just deliver a better deal under the
Common Agricultural Policy it takes us
out of the sea ap or completely meaning
we can design new systems
support for farmers that work for the UK
and in fishing it does not just deliver
a bigger annual quota within the Common
Fisheries Policy it sets us free of the
CFP for good and forever the UK will be
an independent coastal state once again
in full sovereign control of our waters
able to decide for ourselves who we
allow to fish in them without excess not
tied to any other aspect of our economic
partnership that is in our national
interest to on borders laws and money
this deal delivers for the British
people but I have been just as
determined that as well as taking back
control this should be a deal that
protects the things we value in our
relationship with our European friends
and sets us on course for a future of
opportunity and prosperity and this deal
does that too so if your family's
livelihood depends on a skilled job in
our manufacturing sector you need a deal
that keeps goods flowing easily across
borders and keeps supply chains intact
this deal does that we will be outside
the single market in the customs union
but have an economic partnership with
the EU closer than any other country
enjoys good for business and in our
national interest if you're one of the
over 3 million EU citizens who has come
and built your life in the UK come to be
our colleagues our neighbors and our
friends you need a deal that guarantees
your rights if you're one of the almost
1 million UK nationals living elsewhere
in the EU you need the same this deal
delivers for you all and because each
one of us is made safer by the close
security cooperation between the UK and
the EU we all need a deal that keeps
that close partnership intact and this
deal does that too as Prime Minister of
the United Kingdom I have felt very
keenly my responsibility to deliver a
deal that works for the whole UK and for
all of its parts so what we have agreed
protects the constitutional integrity of
the United Kingdom we rejected proposals
which would have compromised that
integrity and insisted on keeping all
parts of our UK in a single customs
terror
this deal delivers that it also honors
the solemn commitment we made to the
people of Northern Ireland that there
should be no hard border between
Northern Ireland and Ireland this deal
will safeguard the hard-won progress of
the last 20 years and allow the people
of that part of our United Kingdom to
carry on living their lives as they do
today this is a deal that works for the
whole UK family including our overseas
territories and the Crown Dependencies
on Gibraltar
we have worked constructively with Spain
throughout this process and I want to
thank Fabien Picardo for the statesman
like role he has played we have ensured
that Gibraltar is covered by withdrawal
agreement and by the implementation
period let no one be in any doubt for
the future partnership the UK will be
negotiating for the whole UK family
including Gibraltar
I am proud that you brought our is
British and its constitutional status
will not change the deal we have agreed
today unlocks a bright future for the UK
outside the EU we will be able to strike
new trade deals around the world and
open up new markets in the world's
fastest-growing economies we will be
able to focus our energies on the many
other important matter issues that
matter to the British people at home
creating more good jobs and spreading
prosperity more widely taking care of
our public services like the NHS and
schools building more homes and tackling
the social injustice ease that prevent
too many people fulfilling their
potential in any negotiation you do not
get everything you want you need to
identify what your vital interests are
and stick to them but be prepared to
compromise in other areas in order to
achieve a result I think the British
people understand that when they look at
this deal they will see it as a good one
for our country and that it is in the
national interest for everyone to get
behind it it all as the referendum
protects what we value and sets us on
course for a bright future today marks
the culmination of our exit negotiations
with the EU but it also marks the start
of a crucial national debate in our
country over the next
two weeks before Christmas MPs will vote
on this deal it will be one of the most
significant votes that Parliament is
held for many years on it will depend
whether we move forward together into a
brighter future or open the door to yet
more division and uncertainty the
British people don't want to spend any
more time arguing about brexit they want
a good deal done that fulfills the vote
and allows us to come together again as
a country so I will take this deal back
to the House of Commons confident we
have achieved the best deal available
and full of optimism about the future of
our country in Parliament and Beyond it
I will make the case for this deal with
all my heart and I look forward to that
campaign